dramatic improvements in life expectancy
have occurred over the past century
globally it has more than doubled and is
expected to rise by another six years by
2050 wealthy countries have the highest
life expectancies people in Japan can
now expect to live beyond 84 years when
records began it had 153 centenarians in
2018 it had nearly 70,000 the people of
Okinawa live longer than anywhere else
in the world their secret to long life
could in part be due to a low-fat
low-salt mainly fish and vegetable diet
the five countries that have the
shortest life expectancy are all in
Africa the su2 is at the bottom of the
ranking but life expectancy across
Africa has actually risen substantially
since 1925 and it has experienced the
biggest surge in recent years
[Music]
improvements in child survival and
progress in combating infectious
diseases such as HIV have contributed to
the increased average lifespan across
the world the inequality gap in life
expectancy between rich and poor
countries is shrinking
[Music]
a century ago South Koreans life
expectancy was as low as 23 years
but to study of the 35 richest countries
predicts a girl born in South Korea in
2030 is likely to live past her 90th
birthday
[Music]
South Korea's annual GDP per person is
more than 20 times the level in 1960 and
these economic games have improved the
nation's health
South Korea is predicted to leapfrog 18
other rich countries by 2030 to take
Japan's top spot and as countries become
richer more people should have access to
better health care pushing global life
expectancy higher still
you